lançou sejam bem vindos a mais um vídeo
e hoje vou ensinar como fazer uma bola
que vibra e depois vocês podem escolher
se querem transformá-la numa bola no
chão ou então uma porta é boa e vou usar
e que o motor de um dvd player ante uma
só vez não tiverem deixe não tem
problema nenhum vocês podem usar o que
você estiver lá em casa desde que caiba
na bola e ao rodar no batan na bateria
aí o projeto é bastante simples e eu
espero que gostem isso então pronto
agora é possível o tutorial
o forró
o co
se vocês quiserem que as bolas vibra
mais vocês podem aumentar a voltagem e o
peso tem naquela parte lucrativa
agora é importante rever suntour aguenta
com esse peso e essa voltagem é enchente
do fim eu espero que tenham gostado se
você tiver alguma sugestão de alguns
projetos são jardins comunitários que
isso muito obrigado a disputar o próximo
mundial